hello everybody my name is marsh
what have you guys got me into man I
this is slanty toughen up markiplier and
I don't even want to play this game the
thumbnail alone is just staring at me in
the face and it's it's mortifying and
that's even worse
good god that needs to end just getting
to the game oh that's good yeah
okay I can either play big dusk or night
I'm good I ain't no [ __ ] saman I played
it the scariest setting like I'm are not
already collect all ten Teletubby
custards what my mouse is still in here
that's probably gonna not be good yeah
my mouse is gonna go right off the
screen what am I gonna do about that yep
it's gone okay uh-huh uh-huh that
doesn't help me at all that doesn't help
me at all wha I don't like this mmm I
don't like this
okay standard woods it's obviously
called Slendy Tubby's your slender
Tubby's is this some tubby tubby custard
and I got a dude 360 couple 360 before
my mouse KITT what's up oh wait Amaya
Teletubby
how do i how do I get you I'm coming
oh I just walked over it okay so I don't
need to click ah that's a good sign I
like that I don't see a path then again
I don't know what the hell is going on
in here anyway so whoa just get my mouse
off the screen I probably just turned
right back around to where I was coming
from oh well who cares I certainly don't
then again I don't even know what's
going on but I'm a pretend like I do
I actually didn't watch Teletubbies when
I was a kid I mean I know of them I just
don't know why anyone in their right
mind would ever make a game
like this deranged maniac evil genius
type yeah I think I'm on sort of a path
I mean it gets kind of dirty here and uh
I don't even want to know what Teletubby
custard is it wasn't reassuring when the
letters describing it we're all white
and goopy anyway just walking through
the woods when is this was that what are
you what are you I click on you know
once again I cannot get that mouse out
of here hub through for 360 okay I can
jump I couldn't jump in the other ones I
knew was that a player has collected two
of ten custards a player you can't even
use my name so impersonal so far no sign
of any demon Teletubbies besides me I
guess secret twist at the end who said
I'm really the demon and uh ooh what's
with the tree how dunno hungers
following the path there's no way in
hell I'm going into the woods could
screw that and screw that good God and I
hear a sound of a siren Teletubby oh oh
oh no okay here we go
I hear a siren Teletubby into the
distance calling me towards my death I'm
guessing one of those footsteps sounds
like they're coming from behind me haha
what was that I wasn't even scary it was
just surprising it's just a Teletubby we
okay yeah
okay who made this I was just giving a
download link oh hey I see more custard
boy I must be strange just walking
around collecting this stuff whatever it
may or may not be what was that
whatever it may or may not be why do I
need it why in the world would I need
Teletubby custard it just sounds gross
was that a thing in the show did they
really have bowls of Teletubby custard
everywhere I mean I know that the show
was rather strange I'm in the woods now
I'm just going to the grass cuz I found
like a wall or a man but I knew the show
was strange I just didn't know that it
was that strange we got here huh no yeah
okay I'm in the mountains now I'm
probably not supposed to be here but who
cares
haha oh good golly zot is up the slack
xual slender toe because that was the
face on the icon I'm pretty sure I'm
doing a bit of game breaking here but
who cares ah yeah like a boss I'm gonna
go up here where I'm not supposed to be
cuz screw everything about that over
there yeah I'm pretty sure I'm game
breaking right now whoopsies yep broke
the game Oh nope ah this is definitely
not where I'm supposed to go sorry it's
just said he can't get me over here oh
no invisible wall balls alright I'm
going back geez man say what you want
about these Teletubbies they sure can't
climb jeez look at me go alright escape
the torment for just a little bit now
back into the forest this is the correct
way right then again I don't really know
yeah sorry about the mouse I don't know
why that's in there I don't even know if
you guys can still see that I just got
the mouse in there I can see it now
whatever no big deal I'll be fine
I think okay back in the woods 3:30 get
the mouse out of there and uh here's the
road again I guess I'll start following
that I don't know oh why is it in a cave
four of ten custards
sorry I'm man see I want to know what
that what's going on here I mean it's
about time in terms of slender mechanics
that the slender Tubby would start
showing his face is he behind me is he
behind you yeah find you ha that was a
yellow one yellow slightly bloodied one
okay is there like am I am I just
leading to my own doom here am i ah ha
number 5 all right 5 of 10 then again I
don't know the layout of the map so I
highly doubt that I'm gonna get them all
in this playthrough I don't even know if
I'm ever gonna touch this again because
oh ah oh no oh no I guess I'm guessing
that I've been on the path long enough I
need to start actually cutting through
the woods here this may be wrong but you
know I just been on the path for a while
so I want to get at least a layout of
what the outline of the world is or
maybe not know maybe there's nothing
just more maybe I was supposed to stay
on the path I'm now starting to think
that was supposed to stay on the path
never mind
sorry no need to explore later I hear
you in the background don't think I
can't hear you don't think you're not
totally not scary I don't know as far as
like scares go besides the jump scares
the atmosphere you kind of get used to
after a while I mean like most games the
same thing gets you know repetitive
after a while not saying this isn't good
but I would like something to happen
this is supposed to be the scariest mode
aha number 6 I am supposed to stay on
the road okay so definitely stay on the
road for as long as I can
hopefully it'll lead me
ah okay
all right I thought I thought that was
game over right there I could have sworn
like that was in and that likes to
scream in your ear he's a nut shut up
either all right all right I don't know
what that was I saw purple something
does that tinky-winky
I don't know I don't know her the name
jeez Oh a player's been caught what how
I'm still playing oh I guess I looked at
him up I'm uh I'm like I'm like what the
hell what is even happening there
Oh God okay I just some T's two-faced
texture on a things breaking I think I'm
ever gonna play this again
jeez yeah I'm done for now because whoa
all right cool it there all right so
thank you all so much for watching if
you want me to play that again I guess I
will but you know geez I don't even know
what to make of it
okay so hope you enjoyed it play for
yourself if you want to linked in the
description below let me know what to
think of it because I really don't have
any closer
thank you all someone for watching
okay all right all right good all right
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in next
Oh